so when you get out of college because
you say [ __ ] college you were doing it
on a football scholarship there's no
point to play football and and and get
and go to school if you don't want to go
to school like you know you only go to
school if you want to and you get out
you're doing you know you're framing
houses like the old man you know you're
doing some construction right 7.75 an
hour and all this and did things look
bleak to you at that point because what
are you about 19 years old uh you know i
i kind of yeah i was definitely like
freaking out like what am i gonna do uh
with my life because i'm not playing
football anymore and that was kind of
the only goal and you're not going to
school yeah definitely not going to go
to school so i guess in my mind i was
like okay i'm just going to get a job
and work my way up somewhere and and
figure it out i you know i didn't have
any grand plans or anything and then the
grand plan becomes i'm going to sell
samples at dillard's like what are
samples like perfume
i mean it sounds like a real good plan
you had going there yeah it's my
infinite knowledge yeah
like the little piece of paper or
whatever that you spray and then you
give it to him
what a horrible [ __ ] terrible it was
horrible and basically i was just hung
over the whole time in there anyway and
you guys can't understand what the
lights of dillard's do and like what the
music that they play inside of that
thing
when like you're just just you're just
so hungover and you want to go home were
you hired because i mean look you're
doing this you're trying to figure out
your life and then you see an ad
and the ad says hey make 19 bucks an
hour as an exotic dancer right is that
that's something like yeah they were
just they didn't tell how much money
which if i'd known i probably wouldn't
win but because it's not that much it's
not that much money i mean guys don't
make what females trip no not even well
it's one of the only jobs that it
doesn't happen like that and i picked
that so you picked the one career
genius stripping yes but like that's a
very
that's a big deal to decide i'm gonna go
be a male stripper right i mean like
guys will go hey that's great but
meanwhile going up on a stage yeah and
taking off your [ __ ] cl do you have
to show your [ __ ] no but you basically
see it i mean
you shoot everything there's no real
there's very little to the imagination
what is it like when you're a kid i
guess you were about what 20 years old
19 years old when he was 19. 19. what is
it like when you see this ad and you go
in for your audition who's auditioning
you probably think you're probably going
to be killed or sold off i mean i was 19
had a sister went in she my sister was
not happy about it she even showed up
the first night to try to shame me out
of going on yeah i mean she was super
unhappy when you were like a guy who
danced a lot and everything yeah that's
kind of the whole reason why i went in i
i wasn't big i wasn't like really big i
was kind of like more just skinny and i
don't know i could dance
were there actual dancers that wouldn't
change their routine like took it that
seriously um
yeah i mean they wouldn't they wouldn't
change them because they were theirs
they just
i don't know they they basically would
change them because they they knew they
worked right you know i like they
convinced me to go out and do a clown
routine one night
and i think i just got picked on when i
was like because i was like the kids
this is gonna [ __ ] terrify them you
gotta understand like this is not gonna
work and i'm come out with balloons and
[ __ ] big old red feet and everything
how is that good how are you guys
excited i can carry out the 99 red
balloons look at the song or something
and you could just even though the song
was playing you could tell that everyone
wanted to run
yeah and then i think i just took the
[ __ ] off and then like no one clapped
and then i was like okay wow that's it
for now on i'm doing my own routines for
now on